after well over a month of record high
gas prices president joe biden has
finally settled on a strategy for
bringing prices down at the pump
no he is not going to issue new leases
for oil and gas production
and no
he isn't going to greenlight new oil
pipelines to encourage domestic
production and distribution and no
he isn't even going to increase releases
from the strategic petroleum reserve
instead
you see what president biden is going to
do
is ask
gas stations to lower prices
the companies running gas stations
and setting those prices at the pump
this is a time of war
global peril ukraine
these are not normal times
bring down the price you are charging at
the pump to reflect the cost you are
paying for the product
do it now
do it today
your customers
the american people they need relief now
they need relief now so gas stations
just stop making a profit any profit at
all it's the gas it's the gas station's
fault
biden has blamed everyone else already
he's blamed putin
he's blamed oil company ceos he's blamed
everybody but himself and his own stupid
policies and now he's blaming the poor
pakistani immigrant who runs your local
exxon mobil franchise just lower the
prices
just lower the prices why didn't we
think of that it was so easy it was
before us all the time do you know what
the average profit margin is for gas
stations
on average
it's about two cents per gallon
for the government the profit margin on
gas can be extremely high it's about a
dollar eighteen per gallon in california
but for the gas stations
are looking at a profit margin of about
1.4 percent to put that in perspective
that is
way lower than the average profit margin
across all industries which is 7.7
7.7
for everybody across all industries 1.4
for the gas stations it's even lower
significantly lower than the margins on
infamously low margin businesses like
grocery stores grocery stores two and a
half percent car dealerships 3.2
gas stations
1.4
biden wants you to believe that the
reason you're having trouble filling
your tank i just filled my tank this
morning it was absurdly expensive and i
have a very fuel-efficient car
he says the reason that you're having
trouble filling your tank
is the couple of cents per gallon that
the stations are making the meager
profit margin that they have to
supplement by selling you chips and
coffee and all that other slightly
higher margin stuff in the gas station
convenience store that's why
the gas stations couldn't drop prices if
they wanted to
biden actually could take some concrete
steps right now to bring bring prices
down
if he really wanted to which he doesn't
happy 5th of july do you know what i had
about a hundred times this weekend
you know what i had i had delicious good
ranchers the steaks and the burgers and
the chicken and it's all extremely high
quality stuff just in terms of the
quality of the beef the quality of the
meat you're getting it's much higher
than what you may have had for other
experiences and at the grocery store and
it comes right to your door super easy
supports american ranches you know the
stuff you're getting is right from the
good old u.s of a more american than
apple pie in the 4th of july really
really wonderful stuff and right now you
can save a ridiculous amount of money if
you use my code knowles you will get
thirty dollars off and free shipping on
your order shipping is not cheap okay
this is a lot of top quality meat so
make sure you take advantage of this
offer you go to goodranchers.com
knowles know w l e s to start bringing
people to the table create some change
in america that begins at the dinner
table ronald reagan told us eat some
seriously delicious food you are going
to thank me so much once you bite into
it you can either order the steaks a la
carte or you can subscribe i recommend
you subscribe head on over right now use
code knowles at goodranchers.com
knowles if biden wanted to fix the gas
issue he could do it
it wouldn't happen overnight but he
could do it
he would green light the pipeline the
pipelines in america that he shuts down
even as he's green lighting pipelines
for vladimir putin which caused the war
in ukraine according to ukrainian
president zelinski which causes the gas
prices to go up he would green light the
pipelines in america because it's not
just one or two pipelines
when you when you go after and shut down
a pipeline you're signaling to the
industry the government doesn't have
your back so it when you shut down one
oil pipeline in america it means you're
shutting down all the oil pipelines
because there's always going to be local
opposition they're always going to be
some liberal activists who fly out and
try to shut it down the government's
either going to support the pipelines or
not
so he could defend the pipelines he
could issue new oil and gas leases he's
not doing that
promise that he wouldn't do that at all
and what what biden will say is look
this this isn't going to bring the
prices down it would take a year to get
that pipeline up and functioning
okay well biden told us that a year and
a half ago if he had just done it a year
and a half ago
we wouldn't be in this problem right now
wouldn't wouldn't be in this predicament
well it will it'll take a while to get
the oil and natural gas pumping out of
these new leases
okay well sure wish you did it a year
ago
or 18 months ago gosh wouldn't that be
great
then we wouldn't be quite in the same
predicament but he doesn't care enough
to do it he's he's bothered that the gas
prices are hurting democrats chances in
the midterm elections but he is not
bothered enough to compromise his
long-term agenda in the short term yes
they want the lower gas prices because
they think it'll help them in the
elections but in the long term the
democrats have been advocating for
higher gas prices when obama was running
an 08 he said yes my plan is going to
result in higher gas prices he often
democrats would bemoan relatively low
gas prices because they said gosh with
these low gas prices people aren't
switching to electric fast enough they
aren't switching to solar fast enough
they aren't taking climate change
seriously enough and climate change is
very very important to the liberal
agenda not because of the environment
not because of the air or the water or
the sun monster or anything like that
it's important
the climate change ideology is important
to the political scheme
of liberalism it's important to the
left's broader political agenda this is
why kamala harris right now she was
asked about high gas prices she started
laughing
what we need to do domestically what we
need to do to bring down the cost of gas
right
right i've seen a meme the other day
that said me googling online how to make
gas at home okay oh don't do that
please don't do that
you can't afford to fill your car
you can't
you can't you can't afford
don't wait no you can't you can't afford
to drive to the grocery store you
probably can't even afford groceries
there because of how expensive it all it
is and you can't afford oh
gosh i need to take a moment here you
can't afford to drive your kids to
school and
your kids probably aren't even allowed
in school still because those damn
teachers unions have kept it shut down
since
what a doozy man so much to laugh about
these days isn't there hi i'm the vice
president of the united states they just
want you to shut up
they're laughing at you they've been
laughing at you for a long time and they
want you to shut up and go away and stop
complaining a biden advisor went on cnn
and and he basically made this point he
he didn't even try to
weasel his way out of the the gas issue
the inflation issue the fact that people
are really hurting right now in their in
their budgets
he didn't do it in the way that kamala
harris does or joe biden does he just
came out and he said look
yeah you're upset about high gas prices
but shut up about it the liberal world
order is at stake
what do you say to those families who
say listen we can't afford to pay 485 a
gallon for months if not years this is
just not sustainable
well what you heard from the president
today was a clear articulation of the
stakes this is about the future of the
liberal world order and we have to stand
firm
we have to stand firm
now some people are trying to
some liberals are trying to walk back
this comment
because you know that
they call us conspiracy theorists they
co they say we're all wearing tin foil
hats
about international super national
transnational kind of governments
they're going to take away our
sovereignty on the 4th of july of all
days
and then they say things like the
liberal world order or the new world
order or they they use these kinds of
phrases you say wait what was that
phrase you just said they said we didn't
say it
stop repeating what we just said don't
you can't tell us what we just said so
he says that there's a liberal world
order in the liberal world order depends
on
on
the war in ukraine or just voting for
joe biden and not complaining anymore
there is going to be a world order
there is such a thing as a liberal world
order we are living under it
there is going to be a world order there
is going to be some scheme according to
which we organize the various nations
and political bodies of the world and
the major debate that we're having right
now is what is that world order going to
look like
when people talk about a new world order
it doesn't need to be you know the
illuminati and the space aliens
conspiring in a cave somewhere the
question is what is what is the world
order going to look like moving into the
future what the libs one is for us to
have this increasingly secular
increasingly leftist
increasingly homogenized
world
where we all just
look at porn and go to pride parades and
eat mcdonald's
and that that's and they think that
that's going to spread around the world
and that's going to be a great thing and
we're going to lose some of our
political rights as americans and other
people are going to lose some of their
political rights chart their own
national destiny but that's for the best
because that's the liberal world order
the the flag of the liberal world order
is the rainbow flag
the values of the liberal world order is
secular leftism and that's what they
want there is an alternative to that
there are a number of alternatives you
could have a christian world order
that that one seems to have fallen by
the wayside unfortunately in modernity
then there then there's a major
alternative right now which is
nationalism in order of nation states
where nations get to chart their own
destiny
the trump election was about this
america first nationalism that that's
what the question is what is the world
order going to be going into the future
do you want more
rainbow flags over kandahar and pride
parades everywhere and drag queen story
hour and abortion and secular liberalism
or do you want something
more like
a nationalism america first for america
and
not forcing every country in the world
to fall under that secular leftism what
what world order do you want uh you know
which world order i want i want the one
that isn't going to keep increasing my
gas prices
i want i like the idea of having the
traditional american way of life and i
also by the way sorry pache cnn and
biden advisor i don't want the high
gas prices
i'm glad you like that clip now hold up
stop
whatever you're doing put it on pause
you've got to ring that bell get these
notifications i'm very close to a
million subscribers i assume at that
point youtube will just completely nuke
my channel and
all the shenanigans will seem like
nothing compared to the absolute nuclear
attack that they launch on my channel so
help me get to that point okay let's
accelerate everything here subscribe
ring that bell get the notifications
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you